[Music]
so you looking for a job
yes oh yeah music wos mind telling me
what y'all are doing out here it's not
what these undocumented immigrants are
doing it's why that is to get rid of
four dead bodies now
five you don't look so great what did
you do man we got a job from a couple
guys are the hardware store they were
connected I don't really care I do not
have another
car I do have a 1972 Chevrolet
camar you do a job with a dude it goes
south dump them he says he going to get
deported you say he going to wipe your
sleep
[Music]
clean I can make one phone call and
they'll tell me exact exactly what this
picture was taken they're going to
demand
[Music]
blood $ million you going to let him
go you're real the god
killer